we have three different addition
problems right over here what i want you
to do so that you get the hang of things
is to pause the video and try them on
your own but as you do them i want you
to really keep in mind and think about
what the carrying actually means
so i assume you've tried on your own
i'll try to work them through i'll work
i'll work through them with you
so we have nine plus six nine ones plus
six ones well nine plus six is fifteen
well we could write the five in the ones
place and then we can carry the one but
what did we just do what does this one
represent well we put in the tens place
one ten represents ten so all we said is
that nine plus six is equal to ten
plus five is equal to one ten plus 5
which is equal to 15.
now in the tens place we have 1 plus 0
plus 9 which is 10. and so we can write
0 and carry the 1. 1 plus 0 plus 9 is
10. now what does that really mean well
this is 110 plus zero tens plus nine
tens which is ten tens ten tens is a
hundred or another way to think about a
hundred it's one hundred and zero tens
so that's all that carrying represents
so now we have a 1 plus a 7 plus a 9
that is going to be 17. now we have to
remind ourselves this is in the hundreds
place so this is actually 100 plus 700
plus 900 or
1700 or
1700 and of course we still have this
five year and we are done
now let's try to tackle this one
now the reason why i wrote it that way
is to make sure that we remind ourselves
to align the proper places under the
appropriate places so this one we can
rewrite as 300 and let me do that same
green color
we can rewrite this as 373
plus we want to write the ones place
under the ones place and the tens place
under the tens place
so that we're adding the appropriate
place values
so three plus eight is eleven the one in
the ones place the one in the tens place
ten plus one is eleven
one plus seven is eight eight plus eight
is sixteen this is actually sixteen tens
so let me just write down the sixteen
what is sixteen tens well that's a
hundred sixty so this six is the sixty
and then i have a hundred
one plus three is four but these are
actually hundreds so it's four hundred
so we get four hundred and sixty one
now finally nine plus three is twelve
two ones and one ten
twelve is the same thing as ten plus two
now in the tens place one plus four plus
nine is fourteen so we write the four
carry the one but remind ourselves this
is actually ten plus forty plus ninety
which is 140 which is the same thing as
40 plus a hundred and then one plus one
plus two is four but this is the
hundreds place so this is actually a
hundred plus a hundred plus two hundred
or four hundred and we're done